okay so the breaking news for the moment
is that the officer accused in the
chokehold death of Eric garner in New
York City is not going to be indicted by
a grand jury the decision has already
been made this is just a couple minutes
ago and if you're feeling deja vu all
over again of course this has some of
the similar underpinnings of the
situation in Ferguson with officer
Darren Wilson and Mike Brown and Darren
Wilson obviously walked he has since
resigns from the police department but
the protests are still ongoing and
obviously we haven't heard the last of
that and then to then put this New York
situation you know it's interesting I've
only this literally happened about ten
minutes ago from when we're taping this
and just on a quick scroll of Twitter
I'm seeing something that you almost
never see anymore which is actually
bipartisan I'm seeing people on the left
and people on the right I'm seeing
liberals and conservatives all kind of
going maybe we didn't agree on the
Ferguson one maybe some of the facts we
didn't all agree on or the eyewitness
testimony of or what happened with Mike
Brown and officer Wilson but this one
seems a lot more straightforward the
chokehold there's obviously video of it
the arrests which was maybe for selling
illegal cigarettes or something there's
a lot of people saying that these are
different cases that even the people
mostly on the right who are saying that
Darren Wilson getting off and not being
indicted in that case was okay there's
more people already and again this is
only in a couple of minutes that are
already saying that something is not
right here you know they say bad things
happen in threes so we just had
regardless of whether you think Darren
Wilson should have been indicted or not
something an innocent person died you're
not even or someone that should not have
died even if he had done something
criminal someone that should not have
been murdered died now we have it again
just you know two weeks after or a week
and a half after the decision on that
one and you know these are the types of
things as I said they say things happen
in threes like we oh one more of these
things we're starting to get to critical
mass with this you know a lot of people
wanted to believe that we were
post-racial after Obama was elected
obviously that's not the case I don't
know that that ever is really the case
ever anywhere people have old old
hatreds people you know things don't
change as quickly they change quick
often but not as quickly he's like
anyway
so this story just broke I hope again
calm or heads will prevail and that
everyone's going to be ok and we'll wait
out to see what happens next